vous le savez sûrement la ryder cup
débute mardi prochain pour chacun des
six jours de l'événement près de 60000
spectateurs sont attendus au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
vont former l'anip ok ça on fait le
point avec vous sur la circulation
pendant l'événement elle va forcément
être impactés avec un public important
qui va venir sur le territoire alors
l'impact bien sûr mais tout est pensé
grégory ses pensées même depuis 2009
saint quentin en yvelines a établi un
plan de transport qui a été étudiée que
la fédération française de golf
il y aura deux gars officielle pour
arriver sur le site du golf mais surtout
celle de saint quentin en yvelines celle
qui nous concerne particulièrement on
nous explique où on aura notre gare
routière provisoire avec des dizaines de
navettes qui partiront en direction du
golf national l'a quasiment aucun impact
puisque la venue du centre où se situera
cette gare routière sera toujours
ouverte à la circulation on aura
simplement deux avenues qui elles vont
être partiellement fermé en l'occurrence
l'avenue de la gare et l'avenue
stephenson alors vous allez le voir sur
les images la nuit du centre passera de
deux à une voie et les deux rues fermées
dont on a parlé sont celles qui
encadrent en fait cette fameuse avenue
à noter cependant que les places de
stationnement de c3 où seront fermés
puisqu'elles sont destinés à accueillir
les navettes les autres fermetures
concernent les accès proche du golf
national sont concernés l'avenue du golf
le chemin de vilains roi la route de
l'aéroport et une partie de la rue de
guisnes mer et des avenues de l'europe
et léon blum et quels sont les conseils
de l'agglomération mélanie pour éviter
ces désagréments
alors dans la mesure du possible
saint-quentin devine conseille d'éviter
le créneau 6h 9h pour les déplacements
et de quitter l'agglomération avant
16h30
et pour retrouver toutes ses
informations un site entrons dans la
légende point fr merci mélanie pour
cependant l'information